Good morning John.
You and I have been making videos for over
8 years now, over 1200 videos on this channel
alone.
Enough 4 minute videos to keep a person busy
for days without sleeping.
In that time, I've told the whole world, everyone
who will listen, some of my deepest fears
and most embarrassing moments.
I mean I've experienced some of my most embarrassing
moments on this YouTube channel.
There's not a lot about me left that isn't
public.
It's to the point that I would have a really
hard time coming up with a 2 Truths and a
Lie that I could catch anybody on, because
all of the interesting things about me you
know.
I've got very little left.
This is not a complaint; I like it this way.
But being this open with the world also makes
you think about the secrets you do keep.
Those things do exist.
And I don't think there's anything weird about
that; I don't think anyone on either side
of this situation thinks that I should share
everything about everything about myself.
But what is weird, is when I'm feeling something,
when I'm excited or frustrated or angry, and
I can't talk about that, because I can't tell
you why.
Either because of contracts or responsibilities
or strategies even.
I don't know if you know this, John I'm not
talking to you now, I'm talking to Nerdfighteria,
you're really important in my life.
It feels really weird; it feels wrong for
important things to happen in my life and
to not talk about it.
Whether it's on a video or on Twitter or Tumblr
or Facebook.
I'm not good at faking stuff.
I can't suddenly get excited about something
that I've been doing for 6 months, just because
now it's public.
I've been excited that whole time; I can't
pack that all in into one announcement video.
So when I'm super excited or frustrated or
angry about something and I can't talk about
it, that makes me feel weird.
It makes me feel like a liar.
Being honest here.
Honest about my lying.
Things like SciShow Kids and CrashCourse Kids,
which we've been working on for months, getting
funding together and defining them and doing
character development and hiring people who
are amazing to do all this great animation
and work, and we weren't allowed to talk about
any of it.
All that enthusiasm was so annoyingly private.
But those things are real now, and I am still
excited about them and have been excited about
them for so long, so if there are kids in
your life or there are parents who have kids
in your life, please tell them.
Cause if people don't watch it, we can't keep
making it.
Right now we've got 2 things that I'm very
excited about that I cannot tell you about,
and I am just so frus-.
It's not like new hoodie designs or video
ideas or something like that, it's big stuff,
you're not gonna guess, but I encourage you
to try.
And I feel like a phony for being excited
and not being able to tell you why.
One of those things will be announced early
next week; I'll be doing a Reddit AMA about
it on Monday.
And the other will be announced a week after
that, if all goes according to plan.
Vlogbrothers has always been about honesty
and authenticity and just being who you are
and feeling what you feel and talking about
the things that are happening, hopefully in
interesting ways that are entertaining, or
thought provoking, or whatever.
But as the scope with SciShow and CrashCourse
and VidCon and DFTBA, all these things, has
grown, I've had less freedom to talk about
them because there's just more complicated
infrastructure on top of it.
And I'm so happy to be working on big complicated
projects with talented people, but sometimes
I just wish I could take everyone along for
the ride, you know?
It's been a long time.
I'm not used to living that kind of private
life anymore.
Especially with my work stuff.
I feel like that stuff should be public.
It feels wrong, but I don't have any choice,
and I don't know if it's better for me to
talk about this or not because now you know
that I'm keeping stuff from you, whereas before
you could just sort of infer it.
And, you're gonna be like "What the-fr-what
are you work- what's the thing?
Are you making a new kind of ice cream?
And you gonna be an astronaut?"
No.
Neither of those things, but, uh, again I
encourage you to guess in the comments because
maybe you'll give me good ideas of things
to do in the future.
Anyway, I'm very excited and I can't say why.
You'll find out next week and then week after
that.
I'll be cool.
I'm excited to share them with you then and
I'm excited to sharing my whole freaking life
with you in the future for a very long, long
time.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.